um
[Music]
thank you everyone for being here today
i would like to use this 10 minutes also
to show you our recent work on
transmission neural networks which i'm
very excited about
it's because it links naturally the
virus transmission various transmission
models with neural networks this is
joint work with professor keynes at
mcgill university
so well i will start by introducing uh
what i mean by various spread on
networks and then i will use a
transformation technique that transfer
that equivalent representation into a
neural network representation
afterwards i will show you how to use
these to
briefly mention that how
to use these to establish
epidemic threshold conditions and the
derived continuous time network epidemic
models
and then in the end i will show you the
uh
like basically says the transmission
neural network are universal function
approximators
consider network with unknowns where
it's not represented person a person has
two states whether being healthy or
being infected the probability of person
i being infected at time k is denoted by
pi k here and each link is called the
physical link where it's defined or if
two persons are within each other of
radius for at least a certain amount of
time
and then on each physical contact link
multiple variables can be transmitted
across and i use aij to denote the
number of virus that's sent into the
common space from node j to node i and
then i use the w i j here to denote the
probability of each of these variables
that are successfully reset by node i
from literal sense from node j
with that setting
we can write the one step prediction of
the probability of
infection
where here on the right hand side it
basically resists
the probability and negative the
variance reaches node i at time k plus
one
and here the
uh
the product is taking with respect to j
and all the neighborhood of node i
including itself
here we see that the assumption now that
the virus are transmitted uh
independently also independent across
links
note that the homogeneous
transmission probability case was
actually studied earlier by these
authors and their collaborators
to facilitate our analysis i introduced
the state transformation which is
monotony and objective that we
essentially using a different eyesight
notation to represent the state of node
i
by taking the negative
log of 1 minus the probability of the
infection
this as i actually is the strong
information of node i is being infected
at
being healthy at time k
and then we take log on both sides and
take negation on both sides which then
give us this very nice form which we
call it the transmission neural network
um here the precise is the new
activation function it's a tunable log
sigmoid activation function takes the
parameter w ranging from zero to one
when w equal to zero this works as if
it's a no path when w equal to one this
represents a full path when w between
zero and one this is a partial path
there are other less properties such as
this function is concave in x and we can
write explicit derivatives of these this
function with respect to both variables
this is crucial in our further analysis
to summarize
when we look at the transmission neural
network from a node i it takes activated
input from the neighbors where the
activation function are really on the
links
and has a different activation intensity
characterized by the parameter w
and each node has a state which is the
information content and then node
operation is simply a linear operation
summation
different from the standard view of
neural networks where the activation
functions are primarily associated with
nodes or layer of nodes here the
conceptual difference is that the
activation function should uh relate to
links
and that actually has very nice
biological inspirations if you look at
the chemical synapsis connection between
two neurons
uh the pre-synaptic neuron after
excitation actually sends a large
population of neurotransmitters into the
synaptic plaque in the middle
and then each of these neurotransmitters
can bond with certain probability of the
receptors on the postsynaptic neuron
which then causes the further activation
of the postsynaptic neuron
and as you see with simplifying
assumptions this can be suitably
characterized by the same virus spread
dynamics that we start with which is an
equivalent representation of the
neurotransmitter transmission neural
network
discussed
and such a unit can be easily
incorporated into the graph neural
network setting recurrent general neural
network setting or foreign network
setting
so i want to spend some time on the
activation functions that are tunable
associated with the transmission neural
networks
there could be multiple choices of them
depending on your choice of the state in
your constraint on the states
one is the t log sigmoid class which
extends the standard reload activation
function and the other is a tunable soft
difference which extends the standard
soft plus activation function
so this basically says when we take the
state to be the negative the information
content then the activation function we
get will be the double mirror of the t
log sigmoid function we started with and
it has this very nice form looks like a
soft plus function with some offset
which can have negative output
and then one last is
activation function is a tunable sigmoid
function which is the partial derivative
of the t log sigmoid with respect to x
and it has nice properties because
the activation level is actually
correspond to the parameter w
when w equals 0.5 this is then the
standard sigmoid activation
uh we can use these models to
simplify an analysis on epidemics
threshold if we ask the question are
they every language going to
the probability of infection going to
zero after several steps
and we showed that when the
eigenvalues of this matrix are less than
one in absolute value and this would
hold regardless of your initial
conditions
and here this matrix is simply here
means the element-wise product of these
two matrices and a is the
correspond to the matrix where
the number of particles that transmitted
across the links and w is the
transmission probability matrix
specializing these two special cases
where the recovery rate is uniform
by delta and the transmission rate is
uniform beta and then it gives you the
standard a well-known threshold
condition for academic threat
spread
this slide shows you that we have a nice
continuous time version of the
transmission neural net with further
assumptions on the transmission
probability wi roughly here it says that
the transmission probability should
scale roughly linearly in the time
duration for the transmission and then
with this assumption taking the small
time limit we then have a continuous
time representation of the same model
and use the c transformation which then
further gave this new representation
it's actually the standard network sis
model
up to here i already gave you a sketch
how we link the
discrete time variable spread model with
the standard continuous time virus model
so this is something like
surprisingly to me missed in the
literature
and these slides basically as it says
transmission neural networks a universal
functional approximators
um
this is a particular example
but here it means that it can
approximate uh continuous functions to
arbitrary accuracy
and this is a particular example where
we have one hidden layer and the
d-dimensional input scalar output and
this is the structure uh i want to
highlight that here we don't uh
we fix the bias b which is different
from the standard universal function
approximation result where b is
arbitrarily chosen
okay so i want to conclude my talk here
i
showed to you the new uh neural network
model which we call the transmission
neural network
they are universal functional
approximators they have very nice
properties because they can connect with
various various spread models naturally
and has biological neural network
motivations
and then this yields simply uh
simplified analysis for various spread
on networks
and there are a few a lot of uh
interesting questions moving forward in
learning epidemics and in biological
network of modeling
so i list a few here if you're
interested feel free to reach out to me
thank you
you have time for questions
[Music]
thank you for the talk um
i'm not really aware of the literature
but i would like to understand a little
bit
what is the real application of the
transmission neural net i mean is it
something that is closer to epidemics or
something that is closer to
machine learning what is
right now the holy grail that is solved
by transmission neural nets well thank
you so much for the question uh so first
i want to mention this is uh i don't
think this is something uh exists before
so and then to your question is that um
it can work closely in the academic
setting or in the learning setting in
the learning setting one has this very
nice feature of tunable parameters
tunable activation functions you can
have a bunch of artificial choices of a
continuous set of activation functions
which is very nice
and in terms of that academics i think
this is a further direction that i'm
going to explore and how because of this
nice connection with epidemic networks
with machine learning architecture so i
was thinking maybe we can use the
machine learning training tools to
actually predict
and estimate the various spread using
this uh connection
so that is uh yeah that is background
thought on that
one more question
um yes thank you uh i wonder is it
possible to use sir network to design
new uh new kinds of neural networks
um i think that's a good question the
reason that um
i think this would incorporate uh very
nicely this setting would incorporate
very nicely with the setting with ice ir
setting but one needs to be careful what
do we mean by the recovery state
i think like most people think about
recovery state is actually not the state
but i think it's more natural to think
about the recovery state as a link
states when you recover you don't send
viruses across
the networks and do you don't receive
viruses or you receive errors but you
don't get infected
and so that's my view towards how to
incorporate the recovery state into this
setting yeah
great okay so let's take further
questions in the break and move to the
next talk